hello
hey everyone mary here with my friend
alexa hey hey and we're gonna play tomb
raider which is uh this is the new one
this is the new one from the reboot that
they did a few years ago this is rise of
the tomb raider and this is the first
time that they're letting us stream it
it's very exciting we are in the soviet
encampment area which i'm going to show
you guys
and i will show you right now this is
what it looks like this is the first
time in the game that it's basically
open
world where you can actually start
exploring things even
uh
before you're ready like there's uh
it's not as linear as last game is it
alexa no it's not there's uh between i
don't know these areas are really big
and like this is yeah like you were
saying the first area where they're like
all right take your time do what you got
to do get it together um but you can
also like there's like you have the fast
travel with the campsites
so you can come back to areas later you
don't have to like you can forge ahead
like it's pretty it gives you a lot of
wiggle room like you don't have to do
story if you don't want to and that's
great and that's the way we wanted to do
it there's so much we could show you
alex and i've been playing for a few
days now and
we decided to play it here because
we don't want to
be spoilery and
this tomb raider is quite story driven
and you'll probably find once you begin
that within the first few hours there's
a lot of things that [ __ ] goes down you
wouldn't like i told you so we're going
to avoid
story altogether but what's cool about
this open world is there's a lot to do
that doesn't
actually revolve around the main story
quest oh [ __ ]
so we're gonna
kill ourselves
and then we're going to we're going to
get a bunch of stuff that you can get
done and there's side missions in this
game that i've never seen in a game
before
um like
we have a little friend over here that
i'll show you in a bit and i'll show you
the map as well i'll just show you that
now um so
i have a story quest that
happened around here and see these green
things on the map are all side quests so
we can take care of that
um now it gives us bonus items and stuff
that's really helpful and nice to have
yeah so we'll do that kind of stuff
today
uh and then like a little later on maybe
when the game is live
um we'll do like more story based driven
missions to show you guys some of that
is very cool
but you just we don't want to be that
guy you just probably don't want that um
and what about the side quests like some
side quests are sort of like bullshitty
in that you
complete them and it's like oh here's
some xp and like maybe some money but
like the stuff you get in this game is
like actually genuinely useful and if
you don't have it later on you're
actually like like it hampers you a
little bit like it encourages you to do
them there's no doubt that in this game
and this is similar to the first tomb
raider if you guys played it that uh you
know if you didn't get the bark and the
feathers you were really it was
problematic later on unless you unlocked
the thing that let you retrieve arrows
really easily so it's
it's quite important to
hunt and to get all these items now what
is this what are these that you're
picking up uh a lot of these are
secrets basically that you find in the
area they unlock a little bit more of
the story which we do have to be careful
of because there's even like secret ones
that'll give stuff away oh yeah so
here in the menu you'll see on the left
there's a region summary from tombs
missions challenges
but then you'll see things like
documents that's what i just picked up
that was a document that helped the
story there's relics
murals help me learn languages that's
really interesting we'll get into that a
little bit and
then you will remember things like
survival
caches and strong boxes those give you
items to help you craft and then on the
very bottom coin caches which is that's
new and there is a store that you can
spend your coins on a store aka a guy in
a shack yes who will help you get some
pretty fancy items now um there's been
some
there's been some been a hot topic
recently from the micro transaction
about microtransactions and whether or
not those coins in the store will help
you like bait i don't know pay to win in
this game yeah so i'd like to kind of
clear that up we've been looking at it a
little bit alexa if you want to talk
about it we actually like so the
microtransactions don't affect the main
game at all like you can't
you can't buy anything that will help
you in this game like all the
microtransactions are
sort of centered around the expedition
mode
which is sort of like the mult like the
multiplayer slash challenge mode like
it's
wow wow he went down like
really fast what they all went down yeah
you killed three wolves with one
poisoning that's right poison is really
really effective in this game i use it a
lot sorry that was that was astounding
that was really awesome i use it all the
time
sorry but yeah like they're like you buy
you buy card packs that uh give you
special item items and gear for again
expedition mode which is completely
separated from this maid mode so you
can't really do anything to like it's
not pay to win you can't buy anything
that will make lara like superhero and
make you like finish the game really
quickly and honestly like why would you
want that like there's so much to
explore in this game and everything is
so freaking like beautiful to look at
and that's so cool i don't understand
why you'd want to like buy the strong
weapons now and blow through it like
there's so much here it's definitely um
was
nice to hear that
those the ability to like purchase coins
and stuff that doesn't that doesn't
impact this game this game is
it is what it is it's standalone it
won't be affected by microtransactions
yeah so that's stuff like the extra
bonus things like people want to compete
beating things for higher scores and
things like that um so it's a different
area
all right there's a different way oh
here we go also like when you walk into
areas like if you walk into a new area
it'll show on the bottom left screen
it's like friends scores and it shows
your score for what you've collected in
the area and then people on your friends
list um
so it's kind of competitive i think it's
either there's so many things to show
you guys because there's all sorts of
menu
uh here we go
um mine's loading but basically that
isn't that based on that's based on
stuff like
kills and kills and what you've
collected stuff you've done just you
there you go 637
so
that's the kind of stuff that it's
impacting but not the story itself you
won't be able to beat the game faster or
better if you if you do that stuff which
is nice yep
we're all just the same laura on a
different journey the coins that we're
getting however do help in the sense
that you'll you'll get um there's like
new outfits for laura there's um the
iconic outfit the icon you know the
outfit she's known the black tank top
outfit there's um
the uh no no no no
laura
we just want to destroy this i want to
destroy this first um there's other
things there's um
there's like a rope ascender which
you'll remember from the first game that
helps you
um move ropes way faster and i remember
telling alexa like
dang it like i kind of regret buying it
but then later on in the game i've
decided that oh you son of a she
um
you'll find that that's actually really
nice to have rabbits
oh man oh that's brutal yeah well
nature's brutal
he's are
this is the way of the land i did hunt
more in this game than i've hunted
in the last game by far there's a lot
you can do with skins like you make
pouches you can hold more stuff i'll go
to a fire in a little bit um all right
i'm gonna try to get all these boxes so
that we can get this side quest out of
the way but there is so much that you
can do with hunting in this one oh
optional challenge to nearby
maybe later
yeah we might we might attack one later
i know we have to be careful with
you know giving away puzzles and that's
like an honest part of this game right
where we could totally do that and and
show that to you guys but
once you see
how
something like that is solved yeah why
you know it's you're kind of ruining it
for everyone so we're not here to solve
your puzzles for you yeah i wanna show
you guys a tomb and i'd be happy to do
that um but i'm gonna be careful not to
give away
all those awesome secrets so that you
guys can enjoy it when you play it so it
looks like there is one up there have we
explained this survival instinct yet you
hold down oh no i don't think i have um
if i hit in the right stick it will show
me
various it's like a hint
yeah it's basically laura's survival
instincts you're exactly right that
would um i think there's what's in there
is that
that's a i think it's a tomb not a crypt
i can show you what it looks like in
there i think there's wolves in there
actually
oh boy
oh boy guys pretty sure uh you also so
there's in addition to optional tombs in
this one you can just
investigate dark
cavernous areas it's called into
darkness so i've explored this cave now
officially and then you can find the
wolves i think i already killed them
with the poison and then you'll find
things like this
which i can't get to yet because i don't
have the proper gear now i get it later
on in the story and i'll have to come
back so it's very metroid-esque right
where you'll like you'll get an item
that will help you later on uh you can
also mine for materials that help you
craft this is like ore essentially and
that helps me
craft
explosives and other things later on
mushrooms your favorite
i
love me some mushrooms
because
they are really really helpful so be
careful
i just want to make sure that the story
doesn't go off if i go up here
so i'm going to let tano
that we might take he's not paying
attention
i might have to have you cut i don't
want to show story so just be careful
it you'll know
i think we're fine we're fine we're fine
chris is averted we really we really
really really don't want to spoil
anything for you guys like there's just
a huge there's a huge spoiler coming up
um actually it's not like a minor thing
it's a big one so while we're sitting at
a campfire why don't we show them some
skill stuff and sure unfortunately i
don't have any skill points to spend
right now um once i finish this i will
but um i'll just briefly show you i've
gone over it a little bit before but
there's there's three modes brawler
survival and hunter they're all
completely different and as you can see
there's a lot i haven't unlocked them
yet but this is fairly early on in the
game so with brawler this is your
murderous stuff um you know taking more
damage and
inflicting more damage hunter is more
survival skills it's my bow that's my
double shot that's um
there's some really good ones like i
personally love uh as soon as i can i
take all the getting bonus xp because
then you can level up faster
crafting and resources and then survival
is
what it sounds like it's things that
help you survive
making grenades making body traps oh
yeah those are my favorites it's very
fun and you get bonus xp for both head
shots and killing someone's with stealth
so it's really fun she's so cold look at
her her teeth are chattering she's cold
it's a cold environment girl zip your
jacket all right great so i'm gonna get
this because nice
um it's a pain in the butt when you are
limited with how much
stuff you can carry around especially in
a game that requires so much
stuff stuff
so here's my weapon i have a longbow
you'll you can clearly see by this menu
you're going to get other bows
that's what that's basically implying is
that you'll you'll have the opportunity
for additional bows i also currently
have a gun you'll see
you can just like in the first game you
will find pieces of a gun i love the
concept of that
i found a handle
and then you can construct it with that
and then i can also create
new outfits i can make her wear a
leather jacket which is terrible for
this environment it's so cold she'll be
fine
she's so cold and then i can upgrade
each of these weapons um i always
upgrade my bow first always always the
bow is i i find the bow
a lot more powerful and a lot more
effective than the guns actually
oh yeah without a doubt like the
all right so there's stuff there's stuff
over here she's so cool she's fine she's
resourceful tell you what i'll kill a
few bunnies and skin them
and i'll use that to
make me warmer come here you
boop
so yeah i'm like looting this area and
i'm using my
this little tool which helps me kind of
make sure i can
see where i'm going but as you can see
i'm also using it to make sure i don't
progress the story too much because i
don't actually want to go over there
so
the next place i want to go
is
down that way
down that way but i think i'll die if i
jump down maybe if you jump down to that
lower ledge and then slide kill me but
we can give it away or the bridge you
can go that looks like that will kill me
based on my survival skills
that i'm aware of your survival
instincts i think that will kill me
oh damn it i wish i could attach a rope
to this but i can't
some of the
traversal
like there's this guy over here i'll
just that's the rock wall you can jump
and then dig in your climbing
your climbing axe well we could give
that a whirl
oh she automatically
automatically
wants to
there you go
all right safely
safely fall alright
there is a lot of animals in this area
i've come across
deer pretty big mountain lion at some
point um wolves uh we've at this point
we have had to kill a bear
all right so there's one over there
there happened we'll go over there
um this is post bear but there's more
bears and uh there are a lot of bears
yeah and you you'll need them for the
resources that they give you their skins
are really helpful
easy laura
so
you're gonna be killing all sorts of
bears all right here's one nice all
right how many do we have left let's see
maybe three
i think we're on two
destroy the communication tower did you
you did it already i think i got them
wait so now i return to the general for
my prize uh i cannot stress enough how
valuable some of these have been to me
over the course of
of getting these optional a small
intricate clock
things that you can acquire they are
just unbelievably helpful so i would
recommend doing them
look at this time to gather the parts
tiny little little clock toy they say
that but it looks like one of those
things that you bend backwards and then
like fling a catapult like yeah
it's like a little catapult crap at
people
you know like in the last game a lot of
times they would
looks like i should be able to attach
this to something but we don't have rope
arrows oh i don't that's right alexa
you whoops you're right i forgot well
about that no rope arrows today not
today but they do exist is there
anything in that house i bet you there
are is let's let's go investigate
there's all sorts of ammo hidden in here
i'm so cold
um i'm really stressed out at how cold
she is she's fine i'm really stressed
she's a warrior of the snow what we get
all right so here we go so i found one
fourth of a compound bow that's a
futuristic like modern bow as opposed to
like kind of the the bow that she made
out of scrap yeah she made that bow all
by herself
you'll see right here
i'm missing gear to cut this rope there
will be obviously something later that
gives you a reward for maybe cutting
down all the flags there's all sorts of
stuff and it's it's oh my gosh fall
laura i know she loves she's gonna kill
you she's so careful she she doesn't
like falling from large distances but
there's a lot that you'll see
to come back to yeah um and that's
basically what this is all alluding to
is that there's all sorts of stuff that
it wants you to
to attack later on so
there should be
a general
chickens oh no birds
chickens there are chickens later there
are chickens all right so i think he's
over here towards the beginning oh
there were some arrows leaning against
that tree free arrows yeah free arrows i
love free arrows i'll take those free
arrows
i'll take some of this i love i love the
tree picking animation
she just like snaps it twice and then
all the leaves blow away definitely
there's a lot of um i'll tell you what
something we haven't talked about yet
how
good looking this can yeah seriously
let's talk about how just absolutely
pretty this game looks like there are
moments in the game where like you crest
a hill or you come out of a cave and
it's just like
the scene spread before you is just
absolutely
gorgeous
it's a stunning stunning game they've
done they've done a tremendous job with
the lighting and the textures are so
good even from close range and the
weather
uh everything
is really good looking so because i did
that side mission i just got a lock pick
and come up here i have a box that
requires a lock pick i am telling you
there has been so many times that i've
been really glad that i have this
so
it is
very very good idea to do these side
missions um so if we go back to the map
now that i've done that side mission
there's other things that we can do from
hunting um there are challenge tombs
hidden in the area so that's there's
some crips too right there are some
crips now i can show you those those
aren't those don't really have any
puzzles so i think there's one
over here so we'll investigate and see
if we can find
a crypt or two
uh and at least she's so cold i'll at
least show you guys the tube they're
so good looking
the tubes are and they're they'll prompt
you see in the lower left it'll tell you
like there's a little tube yeah
there's a lot to explore but you never
feel lost
definitely i feel like
uh here's a cave over here let's let's
go in it let's go in it
uh-oh
all right
uh-oh
typically if there's
alright
they're like hey laura you [ __ ] are you
of the busy
wow
it is yeah it's
there's nothing better than a poison
arrow yeah they all they almost went
down
yeah you can take down like a bear and
like three poisoned so i
you got him can't stress this enough
get your poison arrows that's incredibly
helpful and there's a lot later on
you'll acquire we won't talk about it
too much but all these upgrades i mean
they make
they make the heaviest work seem easy oh
yeah and that's great like it's nice
that when this game started a wolf was a
nightmare for me like an absolute
nightmare well it's not really anymore
oh here we go we got it i found a piece
of a map treasure check out my same map
now all of a sudden treasure there's
relics
um which i can find now
um the more maps
that i
find
the more opportunities i have for
extra stuff i think
i was kind of hoping there was a secret
in here i can't remember i think maybe
it was just the map is that it just maps
and wolves just maps and walls nothing
over there man what what a boring cave i
mean it's a beautiful cave it is a
beautiful cave is there looking for like
nope there's ore over here nice i'm
looking what i'm looking for is
structural weaknesses within the cave
walls exactly yeah um so we can pull
them down with our climbing axe
there's all sorts of secrets but
much you know they don't
just blatantly give it to you you do
have to work for it yeah now there's
things you can unlock later on
where laura will have
a better sense
for
secrets yeah and things will glow even
when she's in proximity to it which is
pretty rad so
there's all sorts of
she becomes this like finely tuned
machine
that's right so i'm basically just kind
of searching these these walls for
secrets
can we kill it
so squirrels because they don't offer a
lot of meat but they're so fast and
difficult to kill they actually give
me xp which is nice
so if you want to like level up your
lara so that you just shoot squirrels
for hours you could where'd it go i
definitely get bored all right he's gone
he's a finicky little guy
all right so i'm basically just looking
for secrets in these mountains they're
they're here you know you just gotta
here's an impact barrier
oh there's a deer
oh damn let's kill some dudes
poison wow poison
have you ever shot a poison arrow into a
fire because that's super effective oh
i didn't actually
there's so there's yeah there's
definitely like bad guys roaming the
area i got to be careful for them as
well
those are healing bushes yeah that's
right so berries that i think like a
piece of cloth and i basically make a
bandage it's pretty nice
and it's not
you know it it gives you the tutorial
once and then at that stage it's like up
to you to just pay attention yeah
there's like there's no actual like big
tutorial it's like you're in a real
situation yeah here's the thing do a
thing and then it just lets you go which
is nice it's not handholding oh my god
that squirrel oh mary yes
damn the trick is not to shoot at where
they are but where they are going to be
dang it life advice
i need more gear but again this is the
kind of thing
where you learn
there's a box over here
and a lot of this stuff like again oh
dear
soviet soldiers
something awful happened here that's
right
there's a lot of precursors to stuff but
i won't be able to investigate it too
much but we did find a base camp which
is great because you can fast travel so
now if i wanted to and i do have a skill
point so i will put that i always go
with survivor first yep
uh let's see
no no these are great okay this is a
good one so now i have
the ability to use my survival instincts
and it's gonna help me find challenge
objects so tombs and things like that
will glow and will be more obvious and
what's great about that is
with this yeah i will show you these as
well this is my learning my language
learning
right
i'm trying to learn russian my russian
is at one and a half
and this is
a
russian tomb that requires level two to
read now
once i can translate it i can read that
and it will show me the destination to
coins and secret stuff that's really
really helpful oh man that's gruesome
so yeah oh there's a lot of death in
this game so many skeletons um
all right it's kind of
this is beautiful look at that waiting
the area first
fall laura
she just doesn't like falling
she's gonna need to get used to it it's
gonna happen
look just looking at the snow is making
me cold
this is so pretty
i love that
for just looking at her looking at her
makes me just want to get a blanket
they did a good job though with her
animations and making her look real i
love this like if you
if you run next to stuff a lot of times
she'll put her hand on it she'll like
she'll like touch items uh if she goes
near a fire she'll warm her hands by the
fire and it's not a cut scene it's like
they've just made her
they put in a lot of
extra touches that i think
make her more interesting yeah and i
really like that about this game
her ponytail though definitely has a
life of its own oh man it's a little
weird and cut scenes but you remember
like um
you play like a witcher 3 oh yeah
every time he's in a house or he's like
in bed his hair is like beautifully
blowing
in a cave a hundred feet underground and
his hair is like beautifully wafting in
the wind i'm like well there's no wind
around here her hair is very similar so
it'll just like beautifully move for no
reason
it makes no sense but it is nice looking
it's just like it has a mind of its own
there's a moment where she like turns
her head she's talking to someone she
turns her head and that her hair takes
its sweet time falling over her shoulder
and it's like so realistic but also like
very like nothing is moving in the scene
but about it all right so uh i wounded
that deer
um oh it's a baby well
oh my god survival of it you shot bambi
he wasn't very smart if he wanted to
live he probably shouldn't have run
towards me
what you'll see though on the ground is
splatters of blood which it's cool
because
is that the secret no uh what's cool
about it is i can
basically once i hit a deer
i can follow the blood trail
and that will help me find him later on
and finish the job so they've done a
good job with hunting where it's
it's like a two-step process i hope it
was worth it it was
he will be delicious
also again survival of the fittest also
she her animation she looks
at important stuff like if you're if
you're standing on a bridge or wherever
and you don't know what to where to go
next if you look at lara's character
model she's actually looking in the
direction that you have to go
like it's all of these subtle little
like the subtle little animations i just
love it i missed them
oh my god there's like a pack of them
i can hear
you prompted me and let me know that i
was out of arrows which is nice all
right where else can we go
we're that cripped at
there's crips i'm sure
right in the butt yeah so he's hurt
which
affects his judgment
oh my god how did i miss oh this is so
sad
oh my god sorry bambi
oh my god the wall this is dad oh my god
he's so angry
he just ran right at you
all right i want to find like a crypt or
something because they are around here
check them out maybe
they pick your map there's one around
here there's one up here somewhere so
there's relics which we can i can um
basically i'll put a marker on it now
now when i use my
um
you're still going to see
it'll tell me where that part is
oh i don't want to
have i gone in here yes i think i did
that was the wolf cave where you
poisoned all the wolves i sure did you
sure did alexa
i'd like to find a crypt or two because
there's all sorts of secrets in here
once you look the crips are cool they
are cool aren't they but i
i am
lost in the sea of rocks
see the sea of rocks
wasn't it to our left the relic
the relic is oh yeah do you want to go
for the relic or sure
now and then we'll attack krypt
uh i'll also show you guys some other
cool stuff along the way she is so cold
i'm really stressed out that you took
took off her winter jacket she's fine it
makes me really easy
prompt prompts to cut this deer i don't
think we can have it oh there we go
if it's a fresh kill i can i can consume
it
all right so it's telling me it's up
here
um let's get it
actually
go down one the op the challenge tube
notification is just taunting us
hey
guess
what nice
um if yeah
there's
less there's some differences if
anyone's curious about like this
compared to the last game there's some
differences in the fact that she
um there's less i thought there was less
quick time events than this one oh
there's a lot less there was less um
family photograph
oh
late 1950s look at those creepy people
you know that's like
it's probably like the developer's
family
something's written
that's similar to the world it added to
your russian oh sweet so yeah i think
like i think one more russian and i
should
technically
um
no russian i should know russian be able
to read that monolith and find the sweet
coins
um oh
that's okay so those that um
that
thing
pop out of this for a second that little
uh the wind chimes
that is the tomb that's the tomb
indicator
yeah it helps you kind of it's guiding
you a little bit oh boy visual cues
oh man so
there'd be tomb in there
there be tomb in there
um
i am going to
show that to you guys let's do it
but we won't solve it
we don't want to we don't want to spoil
it but i kind of want to solve it maybe
we can go in
um oh wait
is that what i think it is
oh boy i just want to show you guys i
will show you the tomb i know everyone's
like two chum chum chum chum
like is that
on the wall see how it's glowing like
that
so what i think it is is it a mural i
think it might other side maybe a mural
and if it is then it's going to give me
the russian that i need to translate
that thing which obviously i want to do
so can you i'm not sure how to get up
there can you go outside and down and
then good
question
what is this i don't know i hope it has
russian in it
we got a pistol all right so once i go
back to base camp i can unlock that
pistol oh bird bird oh you may shoot it
can we kill everything can we just kill
all you don't like when i kill deer
bambi
so oh it's there oh cool all right cool
nice
so you've been the fastest is it russian
finish my russians
be russian
consider being russian
excellent you did it okay so let's go
my language i'm stuck on that tree
language proficiency increase i love
that this game
like it's sort of because like laura
lara's a scholar like she's an
adventurer and a scholar and i really
like the language learning thing because
it shows like
it shows that she's like super smart
just like picking up all of these
languages and like deciphering all this
stuff definitely it's a nice touch she's
not just a tomb raider she's an
archaeologist yeah and the language
learning is a part of her character she
doesn't just shoot and kill people which
she does do that a lot but she but she
also can read russian she can also learn
languages and she learns multiple
languages she can learn there's a couple
greek yeah i've also seen so now she's
because i'm level two i was able to read
that
and now when i go to my map
coin cash should guide me to a nearby
coin cash
um so i will put that on my marker
and i will
go and collect this money another thing
i think i don't know
if we can go to the store without
revealing story
i'm pretty sure we can okay with that
story we can go buy some stuff show you
guys what you'll be spending your
hard-earned coins on all right it's up
here
and scrabble up the tree
basically anything outlined in white or
anything that has white on it is how the
developers sort of indicate like this is
a thing you can
grapple on
indication that there's something
there's something in the world
um that is
it's it's really intuitive level design
like it's very simple there's relics all
over there's so many i really so this is
the cave that i have explored so it's
updating it basically with stuff that
i've seen
but and i could go to this coin cache i
was really hoping to find that
let's try this one um
i believe the store is all the way up
the mountain it is it's pretty far away
uh and i will once i oh crap oh
she's fine she's fine that's fine
what's that oh it's ammo it's ammo which
i don't
can't really use right now because i
don't really have that many guns yet
just the one
just the gun so far
we'll get there we'll get there
uh there's a lot more they've they've
done a good job with uh
oh check this out we can lock pick it
now because i have the lock pick i get
these bonuses so that's why the lock
pick is so good and i'm telling you it
came in handy for the rest of the game
nothing's in there well it would give me
uh poison but i'm already full of poison
and it gives me which is much more
importantly it gives me xp which is
unbelievably helpful
oh god i barely made that
i would eat it real hard if i tried to
make that drum
in real life in real life just just eat
it
just just dead
yeah that's that's why she's here so we
can vicariously live through her amazing
wall climbing like sometimes i do like
wall climbing just for exercise i after
like one wall i'm like exhausted and i
think i'm gonna die inside
just channel our inner laura and also
like if you're like even if there's no
white thing you can scrabble as well
right
typically you can yeah you can scramble
up the walls um but if there's nothing
to grab onto there's only so much
oh boy
yay
all right
so he ran away which means there's more
wolves but this is an interesting wolf
cave so we can go in here
oh boy all right i'm gonna make arrows
before i do that good idea
i'm going to
all right oh my god they like fell into
each other
all right here we go
where are you come on out sometimes they
run at me
i know you're in here wolfies
so here's another
cave that i'm exploring
there is another quest later on that
involves this cave so you will return to
these for very
oh god where is it
i hear it show yourself
come on out
where are you at though
i know i don't see him to the left so he
must be he must be over there yeah i'm
being very safe
oh gosh
oh gosh
there's another one i see him he got
away
or did he did he die is that him dead on
the ground could be
i can only hold narrow for so long yeah
i think you got him all right poison you
got them both
yeah i can like destroy animals with my
poison it's incredibly
helpful there's the other one oh nope
that's a deer
wait so i didn't kill it oh no is he
still here
hello
hello
hello
like i'm expecting it to answer oh hey
yeah
all right and this goes back to the
beginning of the cave
is there something to your right or is
that just cable so that's the brush that
kind of is a way to basically let you
know you're not going through this area
all right i guess we got them all maybe
that wolf just completely pieced out
yeah he must have like
mushroomed decided not to
hey man i'm getting out of here i think
he
girl crazy decided not to
wait
you hear the music i do
he's nearby so the music
is a good indicator as well if you hear
oh he
he came outside
to have a snack
oh man she's gone i can i can
who's gone
like
making fun of the wolf like
like you came in and he's like all right
i'm gonna go get a snack i have time bye
oh you could take that deer's belt
there's another
this one or this the other one that one
all right there we go it's hard to
remember what i've gutted honestly
there's just so many things to gut it's
hard to remember it's harder
um all right so i'm gonna go
and
go into that tomb now that's cool yeah
it is cool with me mary i'm sure
everyone was interested
just random tombs
hanging out in the middle of the
wilderness
i hate the way ladders work in almost
every game
you have to hit up to go down and then
once the camera changes you have to hit
down to go down
you cleared all the caves good
what do you what do you get for it
i don't know probably xp and i feel
better about myself look at this look at
this cave
yeah oh the caves are like oh my god
well designed um and all the
opportunities all tombs that i've been
in so far besides one i think has have
been
legitimate
head scratchers where you have to think
about it like it's not like it's just a
joke
what's over there so over here
lara is giving us a little bit of
context of like where we are there's
uh a mine in here that was abandoned um
possibly because they found something
what's this one
yeah we got some greeks so i'm learning
my greek you can see my greek's already
two there will be things that i find
that you have to be level four
proficiency in order to read so you need
to read them all um
and it's like story stuff like like you
get a better understanding of what's
going on of the world that you're in
there's a war
what's to the left is that a box there
is
there's a lot
with an image of a city stamped in gold
and there's the profit
so you're learning a lot here we go this
is the coin of catesh and what you'll
learn about the story is there's a lot
about what lara is searching for that's
within the city of catesh so
so
each of these pieces although they help
you in game play they're also like
really nice
into seeing what this world is and what
you're actually doing yeah in the world
very s mysterious don't fall that's
insta don't fall
nice
there's a lot of upgrades later on for
traversal that make things faster i know
that you can upgrade your
what are these things called i don't
even know what they're called
my ice picks whatever they are
climbing up climbing yeah i can upgrade
those uh it makes me climb faster it can
also um if i use it
stab a [ __ ]
oh yeah you can melee way more
efficiently and faster um there's a lot
of upgrades for like killing people
quicker and stuff
oh dear to be part of the works
here we go
all right so this is uh
a timed
drop or i get crushed
go
and then
yeah so i'm
getting to some secrets now oh yeah
laura can swim oh she's new
uh
she can dive in case anyone was curious
and there is bonuses for diving off of
all the ledges
um
so yeah lots of secrets that looks like
it might be the way
out you might possibly i don't know
ah all right so
looks like i can climb up here
uh whenever we're ready we don't want to
spoil it for you guys that's why we're
not showing
the rest of it we're gonna show some of
it where's there's some of it but we're
not going to solve it that's your buns
i'm going to show you as much as i can
until i see you
all right i'm not going to clear you all
right wait
what's in there oh did i do this wrong
i'm an idiot all right i did it wrong
i left basically there was a little cave
in the office
that was we were just there okay that
was when we found the other piece
sorry this is this is interacting by
swimming
oh no
that was weird it wouldn't let me let go
let go
damn all right so
unless
i missed it there should be like a
secret in here so we haven't i love
secrets we haven't found everything yet
oh yeah there we go so here's the secret
that's not the exit
that's the entrance boom so
oh
nice now that we're swimmings let me
show you this sweet secret fireplace now
if i ever want to come back here i can
fast travel to it which is really nice
and you got a skill point i sure did i
sure did alexa so
where would you like to put it um these
unlock in multiple ways uh one way is
the more i unlock in this section then
maybe the second tier will unlock uh
other also there are things that i need
like for example you'll see double shot
i need double shot to do that or i need
to
master a certain amount of skills so if
you like a category like survivor unlock
them all that way you'll get the second
tier
i think error retrieval might actually
be pretty useful sure it's very useful
um because then you don't have to craft
as many and it can be a pain in the buns
oh you know what sorry real fast um
there was also unlocks in my weapons so
i might check that out super fast let's
see because there's so much stuff
oh we got the pistol too oh yeah i did
so i can uh
let's see
this is my new pistol
fancy
uh there's some options for it for
recoil stability and reload speed that's
a huge one for me yup um
probably go with that
and my climbing axe also now does
uh now it can knock down armored enemies
if i do this so that's huge so uh lots
of
lots of options to kill people uh it's
good i get to kill those other two dudes
that shouldn't have been there all right
so now i'm we're in the
cistern
so there it is here's the tomb
um
it freaking looks great um i love the
um i love the way they handled lighting
like the lighting is
gorgeous and it not only is it pretty
but it's guiding you with
obviously not just your end goal but
like things that you might want to
pay attention to can you dive off of
this is there water below you there is
water below me my goal is to try to get
to there
but
no
no no no so this is the challenge
the challenge is to get up there
um
i might start it but i won't finish it
but here's here's showing off like the
water the way the water
looks and
i can dive now although my br my breath
underwater is just garbage right
oh my god look at
the floating rib cage there's just like
a floating rib cage later on later on
you do get a you get a breathing item so
you can like yeah where did you dip
around do you get it in the store or do
you buy it i think you buy it
because
i need it
i don't know where to get it why don't
we take them
after we show them a little around the
team a little more take them to the
store and show them because i know the
coins have been a big thing sure
uh also we don't want to spoil the tomb
i know i don't want to spoil the tomb
i'm gonna
i wonder i assume i can get out
yeah we go back the way we came all
right
so i mean obviously you can see some
stuff here arms and stuff
um
there's obviously some stuff
oh come on
nope isn't it an arrow yeah maybe i
thought a gun would work too
it's also floating in the water that's
probably why
i think you guys can see what you're
supposed to do here i don't want to
ruin it there's three parts this puzzle
yep and they're all really interesting
um
i think it's best for everyone if you
guys solve these things on your own i
think it's more interesting i think it's
more exciting
and it's more rewarding so we're going
to leave this alone but this is what
this is what an optional tomb looks like
uh i think it's awesome
i'm like so glad that they even showed
us like give us the ability to yeah
and they're all like this they're all
these like they're not all like big
massive caverns but they are like these
beautiful enclosed spaces that just have
a lot of like really interesting stuff
and they're all they all have this like
ear this eerie weird lighting oh yeah
they did a really good job with just
making
making stuff look
old and real and tangible it gives it
that feel and it's amazing that
the wide variety of spaces that they
give you like
i mean it's massive like how some how
big some of these tombs are and they're
completely hidden although it always
makes me laugh when they're like
outdoors and it's like how come nobody
has seen this with a plane yet no one's
been in here nobody has been in here
this is ridiculous um
this is ridiculous this is ridiculous i
would have found this by now
with like
any kind of tiny like a helicopter
other way oh right you're right thank
you
i really want to solve it
i'm sorry guys you can kind of see where
it was going uh and it's really neat and
something that i i unfortunately can't
show you is when you get that uh when
you succeed not only do you get points
but laura attains a skill that is
unbelievably helpful
some more helpful than others yeah and
you can only get those
you can only get those skills by
completing the challenge it'll be stuff
like um
uh the world lights up traps light up
faster healing faster healing
more damage anything that's like pretty
beneficial to the game but not essential
to beating it i don't technically have
to beat any of these right so you could
in theory like
and this isn't like an interesting part
of this game is that you could
how do i
leave uh you can give this game to like
i don't know someone who
isn't very good and they could probably
forge through it just by not getting any
of these things done however for the
completionist for like uh people like
myself i have another build i have this
game this is a new uh
that i made specifically that didn't
have all the bonuses that i don't want
to give away but um
there is
uh this
is
filled with stuff and i've spent
four maybe five hours just getting all
the stuff in one area like last night
all i did was get everything i could in
this area with all my new items
i didn't progress the story in four
hours and i just like found
you know i found all this goo there's
all this stuff in here so much stuff all
right so where do you want me to go
um i obviously don't want to go here
if we climb i think the store that's the
store right there see where that little
line is that is the store so i will not
progress the story no i think it's just
beating up dudes
all right pretty sure it is just beating
up dudes all right i'll tell you what
i'm going to have
there's also we never found any of these
we didn't find a cricket crips in here
there's crypts in here there's all sorts
of stuff that i didn't show you guys
um but as long as josh is ready on the
trigger in case i accidentally trigger
stories
i believe he is
um
you know it's possible
sorry i'm going you're probably
wondering what mary why
who you might be asking yourself mary
why are you going backwards and the
reality is is i've already been up there
and i lit a fire so i'm gonna fast
travel there heck yeah that makes more
sense so we will
sorry fast travel
to
their
place
and then i will save myself a butt load
of climbing time
so if i happen to trigger a story we'll
just cut to us and we'll talk about you
know what we're going to eat for lunch
today
or like
the weather which has been how about
that yeah it's cold well it is november
also we're wieners it's like cold for us
but if you live anywhere else in the
world it's like shut up i lived in new
england my whole life winters were bad
i've spent one year here and i'm already
a cold weenie i was
born in buffalo we get more snow than
your mama can handle
we which is none are known for the lake
effect um it is just absurd how much
snow
we can get the lake effect yeah so
there's uh great lakes near us and
because of that it basically soaks up
the water it goes into the clouds and we
get a ton of snow damn uh we were
talking like lakes are [ __ ] feet on
feet on feet so a lot a lot of snow but
it's it's also sweet for snowboarding
and skiing and stuff like that so
all right so i'm going to traverse this
area
i love it i love the climbing yeah it's
great um it's really rewarding it's not
jump to your left lady um
you know it's better than last game i
remember a lot of times you accidentally
jumped the wrong way or you look silly
and stuff like that this one it feels a
little bit better to me
it's not perfect but it feels pretty
good
all right so
i think we can go either way all right
which way do you feel let's go straight
okay
oh [ __ ] okay
thanks a lot
and they lead to the same area you can
see it right there like that's going to
go to the same place so just giving you
a few traversal options which i think is
neat uh it's not necessary uh that looks
like it might be important later here's
a flag i'll have to cut down later when
i have a box of stuff a knife
you could just see it like that that
metroidvania style like there's all
these things to do
that i will come back and you bet your
buns i'm gonna come back and play it
later and find all these items
you get like good like you get crafting
stuff in those boxes like they're
actually useful yeah that way up there i
think there's um
there's some some dudes to fight oh
there's a monolith okay hey i don't
we'll see
something below
directions to something hidden
oh oh right yeah it did work great so
uh there's another one up there there's
one right here so i'll keep that in my
docket
let's see yo docket let's see how far i
can go
it is there's nothing story happening up
here okay i trust you i am positive it
is just shooting some dudes and getting
a thing
i'm all about
dumb arrows
all about damaris
oh you're getting poisoned
you get yours back to me i'm all arrows
all day i
uh i prefer
personally i will
i will arrow all day before i there's a
gun there's a base camp to me
and it's more interesting and i i just
like it
yeah there's more you can do more with
arrows too i almost wish they were more
restrictive with weapons because i only
i i just want to be pushed to use my
arrows more yeah um but i guess that's
just like a me thing oh here's the case
that i found uh here's like the coins
that i found earlier heck yeah um
and then behind you i believe is the
shop sweet so we will
we'll get some coins
and we'll check out the shop and maybe
you know we'll look we shop a little
browse
see if there's anything cool
yeah it's that door stairs are for
chumps hey dude gonna
loot your corpse oh yeah you can loot
corpses which is excellent it does get
annoying later on there's full-on battle
scenes
where i want to shoot people but i have
to loot
all right so
i hit x to purchase now again this is
in-game earned coins not things that you
buy correct you can't use human money
for these items
look i'm on your side here give me
everything
out here you see it won't let me the
crosshair goes
what's he got what you got man what you
got what you got what you got guys so
this will be like military rifle
tactical shotgun a shotgun i would
personally i would hold off
on buying anything check out how much
this is
ew
175 coins
uh here's the commando outfit this is um
her
this is the classic lara outfit look um
laser
uh grenade launcher
uh rope assembly
and a pistol suppressor i bought the
rope ascender i think we have enough for
it yeah do you want to get it sure all
right it's great it's super beneficial i
got the monies
honeys and like so we'll do that
although like typically once you find
out how much this is you almost just
want to save for it because having an
additional tier of weapon upgrades oh
yeah incredibly incredibly helpful
so we if we go up there
it's story story time so we should
probably backtrack yes all right
this is all for your benefit guys yeah
we don't want we really don't want to
spoil it like so much is happening all
of the time like it's impossible to stay
away from it you know and it's possible
what's up there i don't know
okay so i need climbing arrows to get up
there so that's later damn i know but i
have this nifty
base camp base camp so we can fast
travel to somewhere else and i can try
to find a crypt real fast heck yeah
crypt
do you crypt it up i'm struggling i
swear to god i swear to god there was
one up do you think it's here or you oh
you think it's up here no no i mean like
right in the area the one you were so
there's to the
go to the right the base camp on the
right this guy by the way i swear to god
there's one around here so all right
well let's do a quick sweep of the area
oh boy
and we'll do our best i do think the
loading time when you go to a different
base camp is quite long but i mean they
are loading a giant open world so what
are you going to do a giant
big giant open world big giant
there's a whole world
a whole new world for her to
explore um but that's basically like a
really good look into this area and all
the different things you can see i'm
hoping we can
come across the crypt just to show you
guys what it looks like but essentially
this is a lot of what you're getting
in addition to what we're showing you
there is a lot of story there's a lot of
action
i'm just oh right we're in the tomb i
forgot about that bye that was a poor
choice
i wonder if it'll be faster for me to
climb out
i think we uh
then to
you know only because it takes takes so
effing long that's in i think no it's
out it's in it's out it's out
sorry
i don't know maybe that's travel yeah
probably all right bye
i was wondering like
why it was in the middle i'm getting
stuck on that ledge on that invisible
edge
darn it her's like man it really wants
me to solve this term clearly that's
what the world is telling me clearly
all right so
we'll go to this one
and we'll just hopefully it won't take
that long and we'll just look for a
quick crypt a quick crypt but just a
quick one just a quick a quickie crypt
quickie quick
um
how are you enjoying it so far i really
like it i know we can't really talk
about it until the environment is up
next week but i am i'm not doing the
review by the way uh mr mike michael
mccarty mike maherty will be reviewing
this he's playing it right now you can
find his review next monday yes monday
at nine i think it's midnight somewhere
around there anyway uh on monday and not
only on monday can we release the review
but we can also
show more of the game i believe we're
going to do another
now playing uh we'll like stream it
again
i think the australian team will be us
playing it again and they'll be doing
like
more probably like a little later on and
a little bit more maybe they'll show
some story because you're allowed to
after the review we just uh you know we
can't show it right now
um
all right so let's find this f encrypt i
it's just like if you hug the walls
typically you tip it yet you find stuff
wait there's a scrabble point up there
is that just
i love how you say scrabble scrabble
point no i don't think it's a scrabble
point it was just white wood
scrabble point i started calling them
scrabbles scrabble sorry scrabble it's
where you get scrabbler points for your
words
yes
mine as well he looks so delicious
oh boy whoa bambi come back i just want
to talk no you killed bambi already
oh my god
he rammed you he sure did holy crap i
didn't know that there's they can ram
you yeah they can i don't think they can
kill you but they can harm they can maim
your bod
oh my god i wonder if there's
up here or
i thought it was like
yeah it's up
you think it's up
it's like it's oh it's around here i
know it's around here
sit back there
i just can't remember
where
like that
oh what's that
oh
oh hey so because i
found that thing
yes yes what skill points oh right we
can zip line here i don't know what's um
yeah but oh
where's the tombs
show me your
tombs stupid lara
i know they're around here i just don't
know where
isn't there
go on the one in the main in the middle
rock that's just the wolf cave right
that's a wolf
cave that could be something that's a
tomb down there
is there something
maybe up there up here
and i like this like personally i love
exploring the world for goodies and then
isn't there one along the water as well
am i thinking
correctly there's an optional tomb along
the water 100
so i'm just going backwards
i thought it would be like right
here i bet you anyone who's like
has played this they're looking at it
and they're like right there
dummy
maybe down here we haven't been down
here haven't we
oh we've seen this whole effing world
but i guess i'm obviously missing lots
of goo
like what about under here yeah this
doesn't look familiar
there's like all sorts of secrets
in there secrets yo that area we can get
to a little later on
i don't think it's over here
check them out
yeah nothing is
there's nothing that's weird that the
crips didn't show up
when we unlocked stuff yeah it's a
bummer i swear to god i think it's along
the water i swear to god you think it's
along the water possibly
all right well you actually can go down
here yeah
whoop
nice um
you know what i was i was oh sweet
thank you you know what i was uh sad to
find out that they didn't have was
there's nothing bad in the water no
sharks no barracudas no bad fish nothing
no alligators no
not yet anyway so yeah
i need an explosive to get in there
um but uh
nothing bad in the water so you can
basically
do whatever you want you can basically
swim until your heart's content which i
i kind of liked the thrill of like
in previous l yeah way back before the
reboot right like before then there used
to be like barracudas and evil stuff in
the water that would kill you and get
you and it was always so frightening it
kind of reminds me of like far cry like
i love the
i love that oh um it's too cold oh wait
no i can't do this yet either i can't do
anything you guys
um you'll see
i don't think we can you'll see
something that looks like i need to cut
that i do not have a
oh and there's a
uh
it looks like it's an old fireplace but
i can't use it but there is a um
you probably noticed there was um like a
rope to cut that would give me a
platform to stand on that comes in handy
later all these things you keep in your
brain right you lock it away in your
little brain and then you think when i
have that knife
you
know i'm gonna go in there and i'm gonna
find some
what
what is i don't know
hopefully it's a crypt because
i haven't gotten one of those it's a
crypt it's a [ __ ] there's skulls in here
what's that right okay so this is what i
wanted all right sweet so
found some secrets and now we're going
to go into the script you can tell by
the
cracks in the walls that it's something
i can kind of
find
and now i'm in a crypt this is different
than a tomb because there's dead people
everywhere tombs have puzzles
crips are more like
just challenge areas where you're going
around scoping getting there getting
there is the challenge that's right it's
more about being investigative and
observing it
it's very different so many dead people
a lot of skulls yeah and typically
there's nothing as far as i'm aware
there's never anything that kills you in
here and we're getting some mad bank
here that's right so we can buy more
hot swag
nice so i'm now three greek that's great
and then you can see the tomb in here
um so it's like how do i get there
oh i'll go in here
um i've like dove into waist deep water
and it didn't kill me
oh boy they were very polite about that
i wonder
oh
yeah so here's a nice little
secret area
and i'll go in here
and
you know you might say to yourself well
that was easy but again crips aren't
meant to be puzzles where i would say
the tombs can be quite
you know they'll stump you sometimes
but the crypts are more about being
observant looking at the world in the
surroundings and finding secrets hidden
without so i found this secret so now i
will
drop in
and just dropping by to take all of your
[ __ ] hey
any dead guys in there i can see it you
can see him in the little crack
dead guys
he doesn't look too happy oh so look at
that so now i you see multiple things i
got i got an ancient bow so that is a
different so now i have three bow
options i have the bow that i have
different part there's four parts that's
right i have a um compound bow which is
like the futuristic modern bow and then
i have an ancient bow they'll all have
different uh weights in terms of how
much damage it does how fast it reloads
how fast you can pull all that kind of
stuff which is great and
and really neat and and so you you find
all these items by exploring so that's
it for this area yeah that's it we got
all the stuff we got
we got the money we got
oh right and then also a prompt on that
screen you probably saw that i got some
points
right i got like points you can spend
those in a different store yeah that's
for
like the card packs for expedition mode
which is not related to single player oh
the snow's reaching down here
that doesn't
seem right
yeah wait a minute hold on it seems to
be wait a minute falling
from the sky that's weird that this
whole screen got
it's really anyway i would say
that that's a pretty good pretty good
look look at this open area and all the
different things you can do there's open
you know there's there's tombs there's
relics there's language proficiency
there's bad guys that want to kill ya
there's all sorts of stuff so we'll
probably end it there for now
so thank you guys for joining us uh like
i said we will have our review in one
week monday uh less than a week then um
we will have all sorts of features once
the embargo releases um probably showing
you guys a little bit more of the tombs
and
uh some sweet updated weapons that
aren't
the bow you made yourself five minutes
ago a bow there's so many things this
game that we weren't really able to show
you guys today but this is a really good
first look
at
um all the different things that you can
do you really want to go in there i i'm
probably going to solve it when we end
this and it is fun and i i
and i hope you guys uh enjoyed this look
at it and uh
stay tuned for more oh also the lobby is
on today at 2pm and we'll be on there as
well discussing xbox exclusives and the
pip boy and all sorts of rad stuff so
much stuff
so come back for that yeah and that's
that's it for us so thank you guys for
joining us and we will see you next time
yeah
you